in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Josh
and grace are with us hey guys hey
welcome welcome good to have you guys
where do y'all live we live in
Georgetown Texas just north of Austin Oh
fun well welcome to Nashville good to
have you thank you
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream we are wonderful and how much
have you paid off just under thirty
three thousand all right very good how
long did that take you out thirteen
months
good job way to go and your range of
income during that thirteen months
around forty and got up to about 80
thousand whoa double yeah how do you
double your income in one year well I
started working oh there's always that
okay cool so what kind of debt was the
thirty three thousand my student loans I
know I had a bailer and you know cost a
lot is $33,000 worth a bear right that
was less than a year's worth of tuition
so I did pretty good considering so I'm
gonna guess you guys got married
thirteen months ago yeah that's what
started this yeah so you get married and
you're newlyweds anyway and at some
point you go okay grace is awesome but
her student loans aren't got to get rid
of those so told me the story what
happened well yeah I tell you we we kind
of started off even before getting
married during our engagement talking
about it I've been listening to you
commuted for work and so listen a lot to
you and kind of told her hey when we get
married we we got this like I really
wasn't concerned about the debt that she
had cuz I knew that we could hit the
ground running
yeah so we cash flowed our wedding and
Papert for ourselves and we cash flowed
the last semester at Baylor and then I
started working in the fall of 2015
mmm so we paid off about three thousand
up to that point and then just blew
through the rest once I started throwing
my whole paycheck
there we just wanted we knew that you
know with with marriage there's a lot of
issues that can arise and a lot of those
are financial and they money problems
can come between couples and we just
didn't want that we wanted to get ahead
of it
for it became a problem I have an even
bigger problem and so we started off
just going strong and and wanting to get
it rid of it because we knew that we
wanted to be on the same page
financially and go forward together
kinda in that's cool what do you guys do
for a living I'm a worship pastor and
I'm a teacher okay very good excellent
very fine
Chris question yeah these kind of these
journeys involve a lot of sacrifice and
a lot of times I'm talking on the radio
on my show you know you can feel some
apprehension when it comes to
sacrificing certain things you said you
cash flow to your wedding which tells me
there was probably some sacrifice
involved in this big huge momentum
momentous day but you're you're still
alive we are amazing
what are some of those cuts you had in
your wedding well I definitely we had to
focus on just what a wedding is about
and because it's not really about having
the fanciest things and all of the
pretty flowers and so we had to make you
know financially sound decisions and
getting you know the cheaper flowers or
the or sacrificing like we actually
didn't feed everybody you know it was
not you know they were still happy and
they were happy to be there we didn't
feed them because that was a big expense
so we definitely sacrifice I think
pleasing other people we focused on what
was truly important and that that's that
we got married and then we started our
new life together and and so that was
what we thought was your wedding budget
well just was the total budget on the
way you know I I want to say it was it
was probably five to eight very good
very good excellent it's so good for
listeners to hear because that's an area
where I feel like a lot of our listeners
and our you just justify it know the
wedding so we're gonna blow it there
we're gonna cut everywhere else but you
guys are so happy I've everybody could
see on the youtube channel see your
smiles that man that those cuts they're
not even then you're they're not even
your mind right now yeah so huge very
well done very well done alright what's
your advice to couples just getting
married I got thirty five thousand
dollars in credit card debt or they got
that much in student loan debt and what
was the key to getting out of debt I
think the biggest obviously it's it's
not a secret it's not you know
thing that hasn't been said before it's
the budget and it's communicating every
single month and being consistent about
that and with that I think we talked
about even on our way here we're talking
about how it's the the junction between
discipline and grace and being willing
to make no sacrifices being disciplined
in that but having the grace to give
yourself those little things that keep
you going in the grace to to keep going
even when you do make mistakes and you
do buy stuff that maybe you shouldn't or
have regrets so discipline and grace
discipline is important in it seems hard
at first to to actually get this done
yeah but there's just you know you have
to sit down each month and talk about it
and you got to communicate and it's
helped us out in other areas of our life
just learning these principles you know
we're healthier you know we we
communicate better and not to mention
weird every day but one thing I want to
know is who needed more grace to the
process that's one of them look at him
well we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's number one best-selling
book retire inspired signed by him
because that's the next phase of your
journey now is to build a build wealth
and live like no one else so you can
give and live like no one else and
you're gonna be able to do that because
you you guys are know how to tackle
stuff and there's couples that are
married 20 years that don't know what
you know what you've learned in your
first second year of marriage where you
just attack this and knocked it out I'm
very proud of you congratulations your
absolute heroes way to go guys very well
done alright it's Josh and grace from
Austin Texas 33,000 paid off in 13
months making 40 to 80 thousand a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
love it love it love it very well done
very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy